Ще раз усіх вітаю і йдемо. До чудового завершення, я навіть спробую за це випити.
Тур Ми тут можемо почати. Так я бачу що в нас щонайменше Чи хтось Другої команди?
Спершу я бачу то в нас є з другої команди.
Друга команда вирішила обрати другу. Відомість, Скоріш за все це такий Варіант такий розподіл але ж подивимося.
Все. Я все. Можливо, вони приєднаються. Добре.
Тоді можемо почати? Які Загалом, ми обговорювали з вами на стандарти сьогодні ми з вами будемо намагатися оглянути ваші проекти, Тобто ви їх можете швиденько презентувати пояснити те, чому було зроблено саме так а не інакше. І далі.
Ми вже будемо ставити запитання як власник продукту тар клієнт власне до готового проекту який ви презентуєте так буде презентувати з перший командний проєкт.
Зараз продемонструємо.
Тоді чекаємо.
Це секунду.
Так. Ну видно.
Так.
Так. Добрий день. Ще раз. Ми все доробили.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm, for budget? Supposed to move on?
Опера Ласкаво просимо Е Ні!
Did that for you?
Хочете більше дізнатися про мешканців нашого світу? Невеличке дисьє на монстрів допоможе познайомитися з ними?
Та їхніми здібностями Не Забудьте зазирнути до монстрапедії енциклопедії знань про все, що пов'язане з монстрами.
Платити свої за вашу книжку. Плануєте свої пригоди з нашим календарем, подій не пропустіть жодного гострого тематичного свята чи квесту.
А якщо ви мрієте стати одним із нас обов'язково заповніть анкету, кандидата в монстри можливо, саме ви той, кого ми давно шукаємо.
Maya de Zapitania. Above propositi always do a contact with negative sooner of hidden information, national commander.
Nestrazhna.
Tot Cicavo.
Добре тоді загалом. Перше це питання мабуть, все ж таки скільки я бачу ви для вас запишеним локально сервер Чи все ж таки, не вийшло.
Як Я розумію, завантажити його на безкоштовних, осені, які ми пропонували.
Дивіться просто Ми сиділи підкручували це все до бази даних. У нас зараз все повністю працює просто не встигли його загрузити з чого можна розпочати.
Що ми зробили? Це?
Ми загризила аватар все працює Тобто у нас грузиться наш наприклад, анкета та демонструє Тобто ми наприклад, зробимо нового користувача.
Поки він тут 1 давайте наприклад, Хай це буде Аустаз даному пароль 1 2, 3 4 ну Хай буде стас.
Яка має бути стазерипер Чи Чи хтось у цьому сенсі?
Це єзерненський зернин Там буде ім'я на самому сайті.
А можна навчитися просто стас-зеріпер для своїх буде стасом.
Дамо наприклад, Ось, таку посту номер телефону.
Користувач зареєстрований у об'єм базу даних.
Зараз.
Вона чомусь нановлюється?
Ось у нас з'являється новий користувач ми бачимо наші зерна мейл пароль та телефон потім ми можемо увійти 7'ю зернаємо за нашим паролем 1 2, 3 4.
І ми входимо в наш акаунт далі. Ми заходимо в наш профіль бачимо що в нас є ім'я тут ми можемо вписати наприклад.
Станіслав ну хай буде.
Не знаємо.
За рік, наприклад.
Від.
Так. Перепрошую, тоді Ґріт з великої літери. Чи було Ну, саме Так.
І у нас потім підв'язується наш мил це не версія тут просто витягуються з бази даних емейл на яке було здійснено вхід потім Якщо ми змінимо тут посаду Хай це буде наприклад, охоронник складу товарів.
І рівень жаху, у нас 75 %, і наприклад, якийсь а вата це.
Так, буде.
Просимо від.
Якийсь там Ні, гострийли?
Ну, Хай це буде для прикладу чиста.
А я вам кажу.
Наприклад, загрузимо фото. Натиснемо зберегти.
І бачимо, що у нас сата оновлюється на всіх сторінках бачимо, що тільки з ім'ям, але кажуть, що це не та версія тому що повинно тягнутися теж ми бачимо, що в суботу залишається в сервері якщо ми у новому.
Базу даних, це фото, піде і у базу даних, але це воно чомусь несеться але тут вона завантажується.
Ось Кунду.
Аа зану зараз секунду.
Мабуть, не то, відкрию.
Я пам'ятаю, як я захищав дипломну роботу і на захисті диплому якраз науковий керівник сказав, що не ось те, програмне забезпечення що розроблено воно відрізняється високою надійністю.
завірусований. Це було у ті часи, коли це було доцільно Але м'яко кажучи, щок був той ще з того, добре що була не презентація роздрукована відповідні плакати, тощо.
Але не ось такі речі буває трапляється саме тому так ви бачите що є певні проблеми пов'язані з конкретним версіюванням програмного забезпечення у вас.
Так, добре.
Front-end versus…
Газ з іменами, зміни хто що які мають передаватися скоріше.
Duck, Yamazoo.
Was done to move on to Brie Heights.
Але це все перевірю і загрозу вже частину на цей на хостинг і зробимо повністю повноцінний сайт просто що ми трошки не встигнемо вітаю віталія підкотив новини ось в нас є ось такі вкладки гарненькі можемо переключатися за новинами.
Новини. Є статичними. Чи новини. Ви можете створювати у якомусь інтерфесії?
Versus to the one you have no.
Тобто, наразі додаються користувачі а що ще не додаються донбаси що можна як то кажуть, певну динаміку, зробити крім користувачів.
Ну основна проблема, яку нам сказав павло володимирів це те, що складно.
Заразити Аватар Його було не так складно але з цим нам треба було працювати.
Мені допоміг мій товариш який працює з базами даних, тому ми сиділи не розбиралися і він мені пояснював це було складнувато але зараз у нас реєстрація повністю профільного користувача, підтягуються до кожного з користувачів, тобто у нас вийде.
Сергійович Користуючись випадком, просто у ті питання, які ми зараз Павлом володимировичем задаємо ні жодним чином не впливають на оцінку результати тощо.
Але ми цікавимося крім того, де є проколи з нашого боку, Ну, зокрема, ви сказали, що виникли, проблеми пов'язані з роботою. З базами.
Даних я можу помилятися але здається ви працювали з базами даних в окремому курсі і там тієї частини не вистачило для того, щоб доцільним чином, це реалізувати у вашому програмному забезпеченні я правильно розумію.
Г так У нас же не було могодібів взагалі.
Ну, там по факту був Тільки 1 акцент Знову типу чи не було?
Ми.
Тобто. Проблема була в тому, що ви не виходили за межі одного середовища. Намагалися не підключати бази.
Про засіб.
До конкретного програмного забезпечення Дякую. Все якраз будемо виправляти вже з вашими молодшими колегами, наступне питання, яке стосується власне порівняння на самого початку ви обирали що Дуже цілком гарну ідею.
Наприклад, створення персонального кіно для вортопресу тощо.
От зараз в поточному етапі чи бачите ви таку функціональність у вас яку у вордпресі не в класичному було б реалізувати важкіше Тобто чи є ваше програмне забезпечення, таким що виходить за межі традиційного ворпресо чи Ні.
Був.
На даний момент.
Та не знаю. Я просто в працюю давно трішечки всі лайфхаки з відходами вправо або вліво з пресу то я їх трошки не всі звісно, але знаю, тому, єдине, що можливо, виникнуть, складнощі.
Це.
Тобто такий інтактив ви могли б вільно побудувати у вордпресі значить тоді наступне питання вордпрес передбачає що власне кажучи, усі складові усе зберігаються не власне кажучи, на серверній частині і коли я розгортав там років 10 15-20 тому різні варіанти сайтів на гурт пресі
Відкриття.
Так, напевно.
проблеми, які виникали типові це переповнення міси на сервері через те, що Користувачі закидали багато картинок, тощо.
Намагалися відео вантажити і таке інше тобто все це називається гігабайти гігабайти гігабайди і це не просто місце це трафік, за який потрібно нам не платити ось тут зараз я бачу що візуальна частина виглядає дуже гарно.
Це. Так.
Але які як то кажуть, обмеження власне за трафіком в яких форматах, це збережено який розмір цього візолу, наскільки швидко це буде у реального користувача.
Ага, тобто ви тут контролюєте ці обмеження.
збережеться.
Тут Так. У профілі Так.
Тоді, власне питання: до вашого колеги коли ви робили графіку Ось таку остаточно який формат якого формату ви дотримувалися це був випі чи пінджі, чи щось в іншому?
Це всі картинки. Зроблені в пен-форматі не невеличких.
Ну, тому, що виглядає дуже якісно відверто кажучи, дуже якісно а які середні розміри, цих зображень.
А зараз секунду. Скажу.
Я не дивився моїх розмалів. В цілому. І середній розмір це 2 MB 2 з половиною.
2 мегабоєві тобто у якщо мова йде про відповідне завантаження у форматі пенжі вони будуть з'являтися поступово навіть на не низько швидкісного мобільного доступу чи ви практикуєте таку річ як наприклад, Ось, там на головній сторінці у вас там багато картинок тощо.
Було ось тут багато картинок. Тут картинки вони є повнорозмірними. Оці 2 мехапатні чи Це якесь прев'ю цієї картинки.
По-моєму Вони повнорозмірні але вони стискаються до певного об'єму пікселів.
Ви можете побачити Отам є Картинка буп нут-к аня іще нижче де чоловічок, тримається за голову от там, видно вже пікселізацію картинки.
Так. Тут видно Бик є.
Тобто так видно. Що вона стискається до певного об'єму піксель.
мегабайти у вас 6 картинок. Отже, Фух 12 мегабайтів. Трафіку обрали якщо у вас буде таких картинок, тут, не 6 а 20 це цілком нормально.
На сторінку Це одразу 40 MB досить вже суттєве тому на майбутнє.
2 варіанти це так зване альтернативне зображення, яке задається в якості, невеликої обкладинки при цьому можна зробити Наприклад, вирізати з основного який сам косучок, або зробити у стилізованому форматі, для того, не у користувача.
Був гарний доступ щоб швидше, завантажувалося А тепер наступне Питання А як це виглядає на мобільному: тому, що реально, будуть дивитися з мобільного телефону.
Ну, це доречно. Так.
На жаль, ми не встигли реалізувати під мобільні пристрої, і під інші Тобто, на даний момент наш сайт пристосований.
Так. Віталій кличко Власне, питаннячко просто про тестування на мобільному пристрою.
Буде випробовували.
Нічого щоб просто подивитися не окремий інтерфейс а як воно на мобільному.
Ну ні. Ми не пробували.
Можна зараз все спробувати?
Щоб щоб я покажу, хто о, це якраз відповідний режим перегляду Тобто ви бачите, не типові проблеми, з вашим меню, тощо користувачі не бачать тому, неможливо, робити так, щоб коли в залежності, від розміру, такий адаптативний дизайн щоб тоді, меню на декілька рядків, було і таке інше.
Під шоста ану на.
Оббес це Воно повністю не відбувається.
О, це то тут.
Отут варіант виглядає дуже добре. Але з початкової сторінки там можуть бути проблеми Спробуйте перейти за вс.
А ось воно. Все одно я думаю, вона не приходилась. Просто.
На Все завантажилося і ви бачите ось типову проблему. Що ви бачите лише фрагмент.
Картинки а інша частина вона просто щезла тобто коли плануєте ось такий дизайн одразу робіть його адаптивним для декількох розмірів співвідношенню сторін і таке інше.
У ворпресі До речі, як редактивний дизайн.
На обрати довільний пункт наприклад, Ось, тут.
Але ось власне те, та проблема, про яку я казав: значить. Те, що ви розробляєте на певному пристрої, зовсім не гарантує користувач буде працювати саме.
Можна було.
На такому пристрої причому навіть саме на такому розмірі екрану у нас є певні скажімо, можливості для того, щоб це зробити ви бачите які є перспективи.
забезпечення, коли доступу до бази немає Тобто що побачать, користувач.
Але наприклад, давайте спробуємо залогінитись, якщо в нас, його нема.
Про найпростіший варіант. Просто як це називається припинити роботу серверної частини.
Ну Я припинив воно вже все.
Ага. О, добре. А тепер давайте просто спробуємо пройтися по елементах, сайту коли відповідна есервальна частина не працює.
Ну, звісно, що?
Тобто, щось має залишитися працездатним статистично.
Ну, вкладки це 100 проценти повинні працювати все.
Форма. Яка Ось тут реалізована ага, книги. Так з вами зв'яжуться Але насправді жодного з'єднання нічого не відбулося чи це купити.
У якийсь інший спосіб.
Це на дане. Воно просто зроблено? Так, що воно виводить туалет. Що з вами зв'яжеться тобто воно ніяким чином, до бази даних, нею.
В.
Ну що ж, не є варіант, коли можна це зробити. Знову ж таки, без бази даних. Можна на цією кнопочку не начепити.
зрозуміло, що до форми яку ви запропонували. Користувачам Це вбудована форма гокл уся анкета зроблена повністю самотужки.
Зроблено повністю самотужки.
У чи контролюєте ви що певні поля не є заповнені при натисканні кнопки відправити.
Ні, Це не контролюєш.
з'язок ви бачите електронна пошта і є пропозиція. Тут на електронну пошту.
У просто наші питання.
з'єднатися не щодо наприклад, Ось, адреси адреси ну, знову ж таки, тут нічого змінювати не потрібно але цілком доцільною ідеєю.
Може бути відставка фрагменту ми Гу карти де відповідне місце, має бути і чому перевага не там, можна створити віртуальні локації Тобто, можна дійсно певне місце, на карті позначити як печера номер 13 ліс, забутих вулиць і власне навіть не 5 дев'яток не класніше буде це
Ні.
У.
тощо то воно має бути активним, натиснули і все Невже розпочинаємося зв'язатися Так, давайте подивимося ваші події.
Такі події тут календар, це невбудований компонент якийсь так Тобто, це не говолівський календар, це те, що зроблений власноруч.
Так.
Але ось тут ми бачимо найближчі події. Можна спробувати не у календарі, наприклад, на 30 травня.
Ні воно не аплікабельне тобто на даний момент календар він просто показує, дат і все більше він ні на що не здатен.
Показник не прив'язаний до події не знову ж таки, через те, що це програмне забезпечення у вас воно вже є певним чином збірне тобто ви застосовуєте мікросервісну архітектуру, ви можете збирати у подібним способом, інтерфейс тобто якщо у вас є певний скажімо, компонент для
Так.
календаря? Будь ласка. Можна не програмувати вставити тим більше айфрейм навіть в такому варіанті надає можливість із зовнішнього сайту інтегрувати але тут ви основну увагу звернули на те, що як це зробити не власноруч.
Давайте спробуємо подивитися на пошук виглядає. Він у вас гарно у лівому правому кутки але як він працює.
Пошук він спирає інформацію, Тобто він спирає інформацію, про новини, і товари Тобто в ньому можна знайти усю інформацію, яка потрібна даємо.
Ну на куба!
Цей пошук реалізований у вас власне кажучи, через співставлення, з певним списком чи якесь інший спосіб.
Я його робив список. Тобто, він зараз так, список.
А можна у пошуку ввести п'ятірку Наприклад, ага тобто входження до довільного елемента і дає відповідний результат пробіл.
То нічого; не буде цілком Це доцільна ідея знак плюс можна це і є тепер товарним.
Ось у нас.
Місяця? Як ви керуєте?
Це фактично частина.
Ну, Статична частина того, що у нас Мало товарів активну частину мон не було причини робити.
А оця, біжучий рядок він має фіксовану висоту, 5 ви можете у залежності того, що ви ставите тут не зробити іншого розміру.
Наприклад, якщо ви замість фрази тут може бути ваша реклама вставляєте фразу. І певний твір і висота буде більше, зображення, ніж висота вашого рядка таке зображення, буде обрізаним, чи не рядок з рекламою розшириться до відповідного розміру.
Воно було Ну, зараз секунд. Подивлюсь.
Воно Так. Тут бачу. Немає. Розмірів Тобто, внос по ідеї.
Змінить розмір свій.
Електрони. Ниж У нас немає.
Тобто, якщо людина прокручує вона не може не зрозуміти, чи в неї не підвантажувалась чи вона досягла кінця сторінки.
1 із варіантів Можна спробувати Наприкінці зробити якийсь рядочок, умовні копірайти і ще раз, Посилання коли це було зроблено і таке інше.
Так.
Це виключно для того, щоб не користувач був впевнений, що він прокрутив усе, а інакше.
Він скролить скромність.
У нас пропрацьовано це стильним Тобто, якщо Станіслав зараз зайде на в новини якусь новину на жаль.
І всеминис тобто воно види.
Так. Я думав, що там ранку покажу не Покажемо тобто так. Правильно треба було зробити якісь.
Так.
Це, власне кажучи, ко класична частина випробувань. На живих користувачах тобто, не у вашій команді.
Ботом.
Ви не передбачили Роль Тестера.
Ви тестували як це називається виключно з точки зору розробника.
Ну, скажімо, так і я працював. З точки зору розробника по стилях який мені був наданий по дизайну.
Ну.
Так, скажу.
пристрої планшетного типу з двома орієнтаціями це теж можна передбачити адаптувати і мобільні пристрої можливості відповідного представляння блоків і таке інше.
Тобто, Класична складова, проблема що ви побачили, Скажімо, якщо у вас елемент.
Ключове питання, а де зберігається Найбільш ресурси єна складова де зберігаються картинки.
Вони зберігаються в в директоріях самому сайті Тобто там окрема папка.
Ага. Тобто.
Гарна ідея як то кажуть для про повного захисту. Вона цілком підійде А ось наприклад, я є це є зловмисником але я хочу покрасти ваші картинки причому покрасти дуже зручно я хочу вставити на свій сайт, посилання на вашу картинку, чи ви мені це Дозволите політикою.
Створена в якій знаходяться Усі зображення.
Крос Орічн Сорсис чи не Дозволите що у вас із політикою?
Курс щодо цього.
Отже, це гарний авторський дизайн, ви хочете, щоб його інші використовували?
Ну напевно, цю функцію. Не додавали тому наші картинки. Можна завантажити мені здається, через консоль.
Або за необхідності, налаштувати відповідну політику, як називається у вашому безпосередньо не інфесія що ви дозволяєте або не дозволяєте Ну, я думаю, що ви можете тут в цьому сенсі, і не дозволити це цілком нормальний.
Так. Це ми.
Варіант що ж, Ну здається, ще одне питання шрифти. Використовуйте всі шрифти.
Вони не є. Який ми Це гоголівські шрифти чи якісь інші найголовніше, питання?
Як це буде виглядати у браузерах. На інших операційних системах.
Ну, я використовував шефти з сайту Гугл Атес то по ідеї в Нато.
А все голівський шрифти якщо ви використовували тоді відповідних проблем у нас не буде Але Знову ж таки, виголівські шрифти дозавантажували себе собі локально чи посилалися безпосередньо.
В коді є посилання на ці шрифти тому проблем не має бути.
користувачеві скажімо, саме так основна ось вона клаус основна можливість здається, такою.
Це в Інтернеті.
Нехай у вас сервер з картинками знаходиться Наприклад, в Україні. А ваш клієнт, знаходиться у Австралії.
Угу.
доступу до бази даних, залишається на вами але не кишується кишується картинки і продуктивність.
А там взагалі сюди все можна загрозжати не тільки зображень.
Саме так а от фермер працює на рівні сайту на рівні сайту який ви туди. Додасте так що не станислав андрійович Якщо ви копію розгорнете на байт-хост на окремому сайті то ви до нього можете цілком підключити клаудфер і це буде суттєво прискорювати.
Ну чека.
Зрозуміло.
відповідно 1 С: але ви розумієте, що це трохи не той варіант, і обрали асану а саме для планування не відповідних задач, розподілу ролей і таке інше.
Але ось реальний у вашій роботі ну, а саме здається, виявилося там ну чи то п'ятим колесом у телезі чи щось інше.
Ні. Можливо, у вас інша думка щодо неї.
Ну, я можу висловитись по поводу о самі дивіться у нас просто взагалі сервіс це прикольно.
інструмент.
Для нашої розробки.
Ну, Можна я ще ставлюсь пробуємо ще в тому що як я зрозумів, а Сана, це більш платний, ресурс.
У не.
Ну Так.
Там в основному за залежить Все немає доступу до безкоштовних версій в такому об'ємі як нам потрібно було.
Наскільки я пам'ятаю, ми дивились, на безкоштовна версія начебто закінчилась так.
Власне Так. Безкоштовна версія закінченість, але не чесно кажучи, ми збиралися купити, не виконати певне продовження тощо.
Ну Ну інакше. Так. Ні.
Ну і ми не змогли да.
Водночас дивлячись на те, яким чином використовуєтесь Ну, просто вирішили цього не робити. Тому, що в нас склалося враження, що а сана не зайшла.
Що на неї потрібно витрачати додатковий час.
певно, і підписка, якщо я не пам'ятаю, вона не дуже дорога, компанію, навіть і маленьку компанію, тому це дуже прикольний інструмент який я буду використовувати в майбутньому.
Дякую. Станіслав Андрійович 1 із варіантів використання асани. Це для такого формального зокрема розв'язання проблеми ми бачимо, що у нас є певні проблеми у процесі розробки щось, недовиконується тощо.
А Ось ви намагалися зробити швидше використовували інші способи, комунікації, які основні якими каналами, ви зв'язувалися і як вирішували ваші виробничі проблеми що виникали.
Ну просто дивіться у нас сама по собі, мейна компанія, у нас є дівчата, які працювали над візуалом і ми з віталій які працювали над візуалом не реалізацію коду тому звісно, що це особисті повідомлення, в телеграмі з віталею.
У нас були окремо тобто ми просто спілкувалися що додати що прибрали, його двоє тому мені здається, що для бистрої інформації, телеграм просто легше в наш час.
І на рахунок цього є я намагалася підімкнути Гітлер до візо-студію щоб в реалтамі працювати але в мене не вийшло, і там якісь помилки, мені вибивали того, вийшло.
У.
Через телеграм-швидше, і якісніше, спілкуватись ніж через інші ресурси.
Але як бачите, виникли певні розбіжності щодо того, яка є фінальна версія, і таке інше.
Була створена окрема група під назвою нашої команди шалені пельмені.
Тобто абсолютно приватна для внутрішньої комунікації і таке інше.
Так.
А як ви розв'язували проблеми які виникають наприклад, ваш колега захворів, або що сталося що не дає йому реалізувати його задачу вчасно як з тими задачами, які зависали.
бути то там такого нічого не було щоб якось проблеми, сильно зависали якщо і зависали то тільки через диплом, і тільки того, що ми всі абсолютно зайняті були цим.
Аа.
спілкуватись і все буде гаразд. Тому вони допомагали у чомусь.
В а Дякую. Я був членом там не однієї команди. Розробки і у процесі спілкування неодноразово були різні непорозуміння.
Тому нормально вийшло.
Ну, тобто це не та ситуація що людина, там не хоче робити просто ми стикалися що 1 хоче робити, так інший хоче робити, так Ні, кожен абсолютно впевнений, що він є правий а той як-то кажуть, намагається завести команду в нікуди.
А ось такій ситуації у вас виникали чогось Ну, просто конфлікт поглядів на те, як краще це зробити.
профіль і тут уже ми сиділи думали чи буде він це робити чи не буде і все ж таки я зробив це.
Що це стосувалося? Того, як просування по завданнях з різним темпом, і таке інше.
Чи ось такий розподіл візуальна частина І інші речі. Відбувся в одразу чи це ось такий внутрішній розподіл у вашій команді, він займав певний час обговорення чи одразу сказала: наприклад, єлізавета олександрівна що я буду робити це як як це взагалі реально відбувалося.
У нас було дуже швидко одразу розподілись що дівчата займаються дизайном. А Ми зі стасом, працюємо над програмною частиною.
хлопці також в принципі у нас така от трошечки грубка сформувалася ще давно напевно, з курсу першого що плюс-мінус найактивніші поділилися і відповідно до умінь і знання я також розподіляла, але там були моменти що я вже думала, може Якось їх змінити місцями тимошенко у них
плюс-мінус такий напрям дизайну дуже розвинутий у обох але тим не менш, як поставили на початку так усі і виконували свої обов'язки роль.
Дякую. Яна юріївна Наступне питання. Дизайн Це важко. Це м'яко.
Кажучи, важко і потрібно мати ще й певний попередній досвід, ух ти! Барах тут ніяк не вдасться який був у вас попередній досвід, у дизайні не обов'язково у веб-дизайні.
Ну, по-перше, це курси з галиною ігорівною веб-програмування де ми працювали.
У і це, напевно, базовий момент і давав ці моменти щоб вміти це робити.
Саме от галина ігорівна дуже багатьом навчила.
Тобто наявність доцільного інструменту а що ще сприяло ось такому вибору розподілу обов'язків.
Перепрошую, можете повторити. У мене Просто паралельно був ще урок.
Що ще сприяло вибору розподілу обов'язків якщо ви кажете що ну скажімо, не багато хто з вас є умовно однаково сильним, і в одній частині.
Я ж кажу: Я дивилася на комфортну роботу, типу: щоб Наприклад, якщо дівчата, є у комфортно працювати разом, то відповідно, і робота пішла, б активніше Якщо у них сприятливе середовище для співпраці, і Ну, якось приспіну за цим за темпераментом.
Також якось розподіляла дивилася вжебічна особистісні якості.
Ну, чому можу додати трішки просто дивіться я міг би так би піти в дизайну.
А так-так.
Цей дизайн я теж можу малювати. Але я просто знав, що ми будемо підключувати базу даних, я з ним ніколи не працював з базами імені було просто як для себе цікавіше вибрати тут сторону.
Кодингу між дизайном. Тому, що з дизайном Я спів А бази даних мені тут павло володимирович навчав давав якісь поради?
Тому думаю, що поки є такий шанс чому б не спробувати Тому просто доречніше, було вибрати кодинг в цей раз.
Так особистісні інтереси, також кожного щоб кому більше цікаво, і що у кого більше виходить так Судячи з минулого досвіду, і розподілялися.
І так.
Ну, так необ необ необхідно щоб увиваються.
Ну, було і декілька зізвонів в принципі а щоб якось конкретно зустрічатися групою зустрілись на день вишиванки і все?
Жук.
Оце Так! Ми ще з дівчатою з веронікою з фотографій і по поводу стилів шрифтів Ми робили архів з нею разом щоб було легше переносити в коден я допомагав просто оформити нам щоб нам було легше це читати всі картинки збирали шрифти та кольори, сайту верхівки.
І це при тому, що у всіх телеграм, А чому ще й дисконт крім телеграму.
Ну, ми могли і в зоні зокрема ми вже давно-бавлені. І вже сиділи обговорювали ще інші дисципліни, і під боком було ближче так мовити.
Крім вас та вашої колеги як взагалі дисконт серед ваших товаришів поширений.
Мені здається, що дескоратор. Поджується. Мені здається.
Ну, я особисто користуюсь ним дуже активно.
Я також Кожен вечір в ньому. Сиджу.
У студентстві і тільки там був цей момент що групи з дітьми були в дискорді і для мене це не скажу, що найважливіше але тим не менш, зараз він у мене є і навіть коли інколи також з дівчатами.
Я дуже-дуже рідко я скажу чесно. Що він ним почала Якось користуватися. Коли я була волонтером.
Можемо зустрітися є пропозиція піти в дисконт, тому можна і таке?
дискурсуємо чи мій там або розумний приклад.
Дякую. Тобто дисконт вбирає в себе владових які виконують окреме програмне забезпечення типу планування, задач нам календаря нагадування, є Така функціональність.
Функціоналом, таким зазвичай була я Ну, типу так то якщо там були от якісь маски типу я особисто могла нагадувати що як у вас справи. Йдуть типу там тиждень є такий мовний термін чи треба допомога і такого плану і з хлопцями, приблизно так само.
Так, у нас є відігравала.
Для планування Мої колеги часто використовують там на телефоні такі собі додатки для закладок вони вирішують що потрібно там узяти у магазині, і на таку дату чи не забути здзвонитися і таке інше.
Я використовую багато десятиліть, не календар для того, щоб зрозуміти що в мене взагалі коїться на певну дату а як ви це тримаєте в пам'яті, чи в яких інший спосіб як ви не втрачаєте фокусу.
видаляю додаю щось нове, і я працюю в мене в телеграмі.
Грузія Ваші особисті нагадування ніхто не може їх побачити.
Ну, це так так це все особисто просто для мене.
А у групі це було приблизно на тиждень, ти розпорядок на тиждень, що ми маємо, зробити що там терміново виділено знаком оклику що не дуже терміново такі другорядні, моменти які не займають багато часу і енергозатратні відповідно трошки нижче по списку.
Це з розподілом ресурсів я часто підходжу до дедлайну з невиконаним завданням, після дедлайну його виконую і таке інше.
З самого початку. Вашої роботи. Ви знаєте, завжди який є дедлайн Але традиційно в мене типова проблема.
Враховуючи що у вас багато завдань, як ви контролюєте себе крім відповідного нагадування, Ось, наприклад, у вас там 3 тижні.
Залишилося дедлайна все розпочинається. Стрес чи якось іншим способом що ви коригуєте завдання зменшуєте чи переформулюєте як ви боретеся з цим.
Ну, От як вже було показано у нашій роботі. То були такі можливо, певні елементи, що не геть включені які ми планували включити на початку але було рішення, бо знову ж таки, зараз для четвертого курсу дуже важкі часи.
Скажімо, так, наша група їх не переживає по-особливому важко то такі моменти, звісно, коригувалися тим, що або зменшували все обсяг або знову ж таки, як казав станіслав ділився трішечки там могли 1 одному.
Передати відповідальність за певні завдання, або ж, накопичувався того часу, поки вже не буде пікового моменту, коли це вже все треба буде зробити.
Дякую. Яна юріївна ви були координатором. Але цілком можлива, ситуація.
І в мене таке неодноразово було тяжка Хвороба в себе в родичів. Те, що я абсолютно не в ресурсі, і щоб не розвалилися в мене має бути резерв тобто людина, яка може підхопити тощо як у вас у вашій команді, було з резервування зокрема розпочинаючи з резервування ваші якщо дійсно у вас
проблеми хто б міг ще виконати Ось таку координуючу роль.
Ну, по-перше, я не вважаю, що моя роль. Тут найголовніша типу: в мене не було настільки багато обов'язків як у дівчат Як у хлопців, типу: я вважаю, що я можливо, зробила навіть найменший внесок у цей проєкт і тому я не думаю, що для мене це було супере якусь енергозатратно.
падала цей момент з координуванням і коригуванням певних моментів а Так, я ж скажу я не вважаю, що моя роль тут ключова.
Дякую. Павло Володимирович. У вас ще є багато запитань. Перепрошую.
Що я відняв ваш час.
Там відповідь на всі запитання вже позадавали Чи ще хотів хоча б.
дизайну Але те, що я зрозумів, хоча б я думаю, що варто було б якщо б цей курс був у вас хоча б минулому, семестрі раніше, я думаю, що в нас би було нас би це пройшло більш успішніше хоча б в тому що у вас не було такого великого навантаження на дипломних роботах.
Адже є ті додатки які цілком виключно на клієнтському варіанті, будуть доцільним чином, працювати.
Це було трошки доречніше. Ну, напевно, саме ми вже проходили по це повністю розповіли про це а в цьому семестрі, ми вже робили легше мені здається, і менше, по часу.
клієнтської частини. Я хотів ось так розділити у той час як я бачу, що у ваших кваліфікаційних роботах ви якраз використовуєте також різні веб-технології якщо не помиляюсь яна юріївна у вас якраз використовується непітон на сировини Я не зрозумів, як ваша розробка вашого додатку
Угу.
Власне кажучи, питання не щодо того, а чи вплинуло на те, що ви робили за цим проєктом а ваші кваліфікаційні роботи, чи навпаки, можливо, щось там із виконання кваліфікаційних робот допомогло при виконанні цього проєкту які ваші думки з цього приводу.
Джавоскріп.
Окрім цього, я ще при роботі З цим проектом, багато чого для себе занотував що Можливо, титав кваліфікаційно то роблю трошечки якісь моменти.
Ну мені Якось воно 50 на 50 просто в моїй роботі не кваліфікаційні було потрібно джазки, у фрагменті і зробилось так що воно нас йшло паралельно тобто ось наш веб-сайт і має кваліфікаційне і я щось від оцюдачерпнув і додав туди тому що мені там було потрібно кнопкою з
дією і там маленький це був і а туди, витягнув щось сюди, тому воно взаємно допомогло все відтоді йдіть сюди.
Якби у вас була можливість спробувати зробити командний проєкт, в якому би ще іншому предметі вам було б це новий це доцільним.
Дякую. Ну, і мабуть, останнє запитання. У процесі. Ви відчували що можливо, деякі речі.
Можна було б зробити інакше. Деякі раніше то те ж саме відчувають і ми з Павлом володимировичем.
З якого предмету доцільно можуть спробувати робити Ось такі командні проекти.
Не з дисципліни відповідь.
Так з дисципліни з якоїсь діяльності, тощо.
Угу.
Не основа навіть нове програмування. Це зрозуміло, що з інших не знаю, навіть.
Треба подумати.
на репозитарі коду й розгублено проєкт Ну, це Власне кажучи, буде Спільне далі прохання завантажити файл з описом власного внеску у проєкт не у дуже короткій вільній формі і третя для тих, хто не заповнив ще відповідну форму зворотного зв'язку не спробувати це доробити і після
того, як відповідний блок буде заповнений. Я вважаю, повністю.
А можна маленька, педанська а яка це форма зворотного зв'язку це щось пропустив молодь.
зупиняє так. Так. Голову форма, Ось тут коротенький файл з описом власного внеску проєкту.
А з гугол-фогу Я просто не так маю.
У.
Що щоб ми не заплуталися.
А можна питаннячко а я бачу що там немає та тексту просто хотів спитати: нам казали, що нам краще файли, не вантажити навантажуватися.
Так-так.
Муду тож я хотів спитати, посилання на чужу а потім бачиш, що немає.
О Дивіться а можна зробити так: можна на диск, зробити просто документи ми опишемо через дефіс наші ролі роз зиму просте посилання.
У будь-який капріс як вам буде Зручно Віктор Андрійович у Файл вашим описом це декілька Лабайд Навряд чи наш Модул буде захаращений я тут додав що додається 1 Факт давайте ми зменшимо його Розмір наприклад, байди як то кажуть, нікому від завантаження.
У.
Цього файлу. Не гірше. Не стане.
Що я сподіваюсь, розібралися, і є деякий час.
Я також спробую докласти матеріали тих занять що в нас були для того, щоб все це збереглося і не буде бажання як ви сказали собі: занотувати і використати.
Тоді користуючись. Випадком, я ще раз. Дякую. Мені було приємно працювати у будь-якому форматі.
З вами Шкода, що останній день Занять таке теж буває.
Тому.
І з завершенням, ще одного предмету, там зустрімося десь за півгодинки. А в цей час я спробую як це називається.
Дякую. Велике Дякую. Вам. Також Шип і Павло Володимирович.
Настрій ще більше.
Так. Дякуємо. Вам.
Дякую. Велик.
Дякую за медика Було Цікаво працювати.
З вами Було Цікаво працювати Скажу Так.
Так Ну, все до зустрічі колись. Сподіваюсь, відбудеться на все добре.
До побачення.
Бачити.
Дякуємо До побачення. Гарного дня.
Дякую. До побачення.
Виключення.